-Hello and welcome.
Thank you so much
for coming on our show.
-Thank you for having me.
It's a delight.
I'm excited to be here.
-I'm happy you're here.
Congrats on the book.
It's fantastic.
I want to talk about
your historic run,
and Obama got behind you,
Oprah got behind you.
Do you remember getting
the phone call
that Oprah wants to support?
-Oh, yeah, so, she called,
and we had to pull off
on the side of the highway
because we were heading into
one of those parts of Georgia
that did not have cell service.
And I sort of scared the driver
like, "We got to pull over now!"
-"Oprah is on the phone!
Do whatever you have to do!"
-Seriously.
We, like, barely avoided
an aardvark or something.
-[ Laughs ]
-It was dynamic.
-Your book, "Our Time Is Now,"
you wanted it to come out now,
as soon as possible because why?
Tell people.
-One is that we're
in the midst of primaries
and we often think
that voter suppression
only exists
in the general election,
that it's Democrats
versus Republicans.
I wanted people to really
understand that suppression
is a system and that system
exists year-round,
whether we're picking our side
or they're picking their side.
And if you don't understand
that it's always present,
then you are going to ignore it
or think that it's just about
politicians being mad
at each other.
So I wanted to use the book
and the timing
to give people
time to absorb it,
to understand it,
and to know what to look for
so we can fight for
fair elections in November.
-The beginning of the book,
the introduction,
you tell this great story
about the first time
your grandma voted.
-So, my grandmother -- we call
her -- her name is Wilter.
They call her Bill.
I was very confused as a child
for a very long time
because my grandfather,
his name was Walter
and they called him Jim,
so it was a lot of names
that did not make sense.
So, you know,
during my campaign,
I was home for a visit and I was
talking to my grandmother.
She was watching what was
happening here in Georgia
as more and more about the voter
suppression was coming out.
And she decided to tell me about
the first time she voted.
She didn't want to.
She had watched her children
be arrested and attacked
during the civil rights
movement.
Her husband had served in
two wars on behalf of
the United States
and was never allowed to vote.
She had been, you know,
assailed herself
and she just didn't trust that
the right to vote was real.
My grandfather kept urging her
from the front room
to come and vote
because that was during the time
where people used to dress up
to go and vote.
And it was the first time
black people in Mississippi
would have had a chance to vote
in a presidential election
in modern times.
And she just didn't want to go,
and when she told me the story,
she wanted me to understand
it wasn't that she was --
it wasn't just the fear.
Not just fear of the guns
and the hoses and the dogs.
It was fear of the power.
For something to be denied
for so long,
it was hard to believe
it was real.
And where my grandfather
was excited about it,
she was just filled with
trepidation and shame
that she didn't want to risk it
just in case this time
it was also a lie.
-It's unbelievable
when you hear those stories
and it's, you know,
here we are today,
and there's voter suppression
still today.
I mean, we saw this happen
in Georgia.
It was insane.
And people are waiting outside
during a pandemic.
And you go,
"What the heck is going on?"
How do we stop this?
-Well, the first thing
is that if you want to
dismantle a system,
you got to understand it.
-Yeah.
-And you know what
my grandmother wanted me
to understand,
what I want folks to
understand is that the age of,
you know, guns
and dogs and hoses
being the barrier to voting
is gone.
Today it's labyrinthine
administrative rules.
It's having to know based on
the day you move to a new state
how many days you have
until you can get registered.
It's being able to register
to vote
and not have your application
thrown out
because someone didn't know
how to spell your last name
and wouldn't ask.
But it's also about having
a polling place shut down,
which is part of what happened
in Georgia.
We had one polling location
that had to serve 16,000 people
in a single day
with the same number of machines
they used to have when they were
serving only a few thousand.
And so it's understanding
that it's complex now,
that it's designed
to look like user error.
It's designed to look like
just bureaucracy.
And it's designed
to make you doubt
that you didn't
make the mistake.
And that's what's so insidious
about it.
We no longer treat
voter suppression
as the responsibility
of those who are
in charge of elections.
We blame each other
instead of blaming the system
and blaming the people
responsible
for making the system so hard.
-You also talk in the book about
how important
the census is as well.
-So the census is that --
you know, it seems like
this annoying, intrusive,
statistical thing
that happens every 10 years.
-Yeah.
-Most of us respond just because
we believe the red letters
saying this is a federal crime
if you don't reply.
But too often, the people
who most need to be seen
are afraid of it.
And unfortunately,
in this administration,
Donald Trump
has been very intentional
about trying to
scare people out of
completing the census
or underfunding it.
And it's based on an analysis
that they got from a gentleman
named Thomas Hofeller, who said
that if you can get people
not to participate in
the census,
especially communities of color,
the nation would look
more Republican and white.
And that's just not who we are.
Those communities
that are being overlooked now,
that are suffering now,
it's because they were
discounted 10 years ago.
But it's also political power.
The districts
that get drawn for elections
are drawn based on
these numbers.
And if you aren't counted, you
are counted out for 10 years.
-10 years.
-And 10 years.
And that's a long time to go,
to be ignored by those
who are responsible for
making choices on your behalf.
-Stacey, you're on
the short list
of a possible VP running mate
for Joe Biden.
Obviously, you can't speak
much about that,
but if that does happen,
who is your first call?
-Oh, my mom and dad.
-Really?
I mean, they got to be so proud
with everything you're doing.
-I said mom first because she's
the most likely to answer
the phone when I call,
but she'll call Daddy
over to listen.
-Oh, yeah.
My mom was like that too, yeah.
My dad wouldn't even go
near the phone.
That was her thing,
and she would get on
and she would just
talk and talk.
I could put the phone down,
walk down the block,
come back, and we're still
mid-conversation.
But I love that
that would be your first call.
Thank you so much
for coming on our show.
I really appreciate it.
And I hope to talk to you
in the future.
-Thank you so much.
I truly am honored to be here.